un acto de protesta frente a la embajada
turca en estocolmo Suecia que generaría
la indignación del mundo islámico
rasgos paludan un líder de la extrema
derecha sueco danesa quema una copia del
Corán libro sagrado del islam según la
policía sueca rasmus quería manifestarse
en contra de la supuesta injerencia de
Turquía en la política sueca desde
entonces miles de personas se han
volcado a las calles en países de
mayoría musulmana como Turquía Irak
yemen y Jordania
esta manifestación ha sido organizada
por el frente de acción islámica y
grupos juveniles contra el crimen que
cometió el extremista danés en suelo
sueco y con la aprobación del gobierno
sueco
manifestantes queman la bandera sueca
frente a la embajada del país europeo en
un intento de responder equitativamente
a lo que los musulmanes consideran como
un insulto a su dignidad
Esto es ofensivo para los sentimientos
de todos los musulmanes le pedimos a la
Unión Europea que publique una
declaración para condenar tales insultos
a otras religiones
Suecia es el su país con la mayor
población musulmana de la Unión Europea
más del 8% de los suecos se llama oma y
Search Center estima que para 2050
podría aumentar al 11%, lo que ha
provocado un auge de partidos políticos
de extrema derecha como los demócratas
de Suecia fundado por simpatizantes
nazis Y que ahora están en la coalición
de gobierno estos atribuyen la creciente
violencia de las pandillas a los
musulmanes y a los migrantes y han
convocado a manifestaciones islamófobas
una creciente discriminación en suelo
sueco que ha representado tensiones
diplomáticas para estocolmo